the Joe Rogan experience to be
completely honest was the every other
record I've made even ones that these
some of these guys have played on it was
much more like I came in you're the
songwriter and like it's session
musicians you know and then you go out
and you're the commodity you're the
singing head you're the star and I think
maybe around 2017 there's a big part of
me that really rejected all that the
newness of it and like the
responsibility of it I just all ever
want to just play guitar and band you
know as a kid and maybe I wanted to feel
like a part of something that wasn't all
about my [ __ ] head right I mean then
I realized like I was finally in the
band I've always wanted to be in since I
was 13 in my bedroom you know it's like
why wouldn't I make those records right
it's funny because we imagine I mean
think about the first one that we made
together right opposed
yeah Bobby I've met I actually met Bobby
before I met Miles Bobby played organ on
my very first record I'd never met him
he got called down by the producer and
we instantly I was just like okay this
guy's cool [ __ ] and then I think like we
were hanging out really good week and we
were going out we were both going pretty
hard in the paint still back then like
we Bobby and I would go out drinking and
they come home and wake my wife up at
4:00 in the morning eat all ice cream
and that was like yes and I think it was
one night in particular in Nashville I
was working at a [ __ ] grocery store
he was sleeping in his car you know
we're both just like pretending we're
not miserable and enjoying each other's
company we went got real shit-faced man
and we were walking up the Mondrian
going to the only place that was still
open to get some food at like 3:00 in
the morning so all these meat market
bars are letting out and we both look
like a couple of degenerate scumbags
probably and we walked by and there's
this group of like four or five
obviously Vandy [ __ ] football players
like just huge dudes young men and
pretty near eiated
and we're walking by and I hear one of
them say oh look it's The Strokes he's
like I love your records man you know
and I blew it off what everyone grown
asked me and I kept walking and then I
got about ten feet I don't know why I
could just tell Bobby wasn't with me
and I turn around and look back to see
this [ __ ] standing in the middle
of the circle of all of them like
literally eight inches from this guy's
face with his hands on his hip wearing
his low jacket and Bobby's from Detroit
man you know [ __ ] play you know and I
was like alright well I guess I'm going
to jail Bob tonight and I turn around
like kind of walked back over there and
about the time I get to the group of
dudes one of them was eating a street
hotdog and I will never forget this as
long as I live Bobby like snatch the
hotdog out of his hand and he kind of
crushed it like a paper wad and bounced
it off his forehead Bobby was like well
now I'm definitely going to jail with
Bob tonight you know so Bradley Cooper's
and you gives yeah the Bradley Cooper's
we call them Bradley Cooper's because
there's like this swarm of like dudes
that had pink shirts on the guys Bradley
Cooper's and I don't know fascinating to
watch them all immediately knew that
they were dealing with something that
they never experienced and they wanted
[ __ ] none of it I was like I think I
this is my new best friend move your
friends was God rest of my life just
hotdog destroying man it's not to be
[ __ ] this just diet this David Lee
Roth organ playing [ __ ] is all
Island we were just walking having a
drink father and no body their dicks
total yes and then we went back need all
of this ice cream out of the same
container with it and now we sleep on a
bus and have our own hotel rooms the bus
things got to be a trip huh it's a lot
like a being on a ship yeah it's just
like Navy sleeping bunks and you wake up
every day and wonder where you are and
but no [ __ ] on the bus where I can't
poop on the bus no my sort of thousand
dollars you know you can poop on other
people yeah you don't poop on our bus
right so what do you guys do just tell
the guy to pull over to a rest stop yeah
you find a nice pilot somewhere in Omaha
and [ __ ] on the toilet the same 38
truckers have today you know it's
already warm
oh it's Old Glory the beats being in a
vein
though by far Oh for sure right so you
guys listen music playing music what are
you doing when you're on the bus movies
movies movies or you know watching Chuck
cereal very few comics travel like that
birth crisis is one of the rare ones he
travels by bus honestly man face on it
[ __ ] I mean at the end of the day you're
not this ant we are very grateful I want
to touch on that but like the bus thing
it's a quality of life issue as you will
know touring is all about quality life
there's no way to make it not suck other
than the show's themselves right and
everything else that 22 hours a day it's
like just trying to see if coops won
some kind of circadian rhythm so you
don't get all seratonin weird and [ __ ]
when that nightly adrenaline blasts is
the hardest thing on me I find after
tour that I have to like figure out
what's going on in my brain and not be
you get home from that after six weeks
Yuki I can't get off the couch for a
week it's like this weird strange
fatigue I've never experienced in
anything else but the bus we kind of I'd
rather like I said I'd rather ride the
bus for three days then go to an airport
it's just you're in a cocoon it's your
home on the ground millyar it's a safe
haven they're all just chilling yeah we
hang out we're all around each other
more than we are our families most the
time we're in this little motor home hmm
and if you get off it's just like
[ __ ] Joseph Conrad man don't get off
the boat you step off the boat
that's when weird [ __ ] happens you know
right
[Applause]